تغطيتنا المباشره مشاهدينا متواصله لاثار
الزلزال العنيف والمدمر الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا ووصلت تداعياته الى الشمال السوري
اعداد القتلى في ارتفاع مستمر فيما تتواصل
عمليات الانقاذ بحثا عن ناجين الزلزال
مشاهدينا بلغت قوته 7.8 درجات على مقياس
ريختر وافادت رويترز قبل قليل بان زلزالا
بقوه سبع درجات ونصف الدرجه ضرب وسط تركيا
فيما تحدثت قبل ذلك السلطات التركيه عن
انهيار 1700 مبنى في عشر ولايات تبقى
الارقام في سوريا مجهوله على الجانب
السوري ضرب زلزال المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها المعارضه والمكتظه بنحو اربعه
ملايين سوري نزحوا من مناطق اخرى من
البلاد بسبب الحرب الاهليه وافاد اعلام
النظام السوري بان زلزالا ضرب العاصمه
السوريه دمشق وهزات ارتداديه في مدينه
اللاذ وذكر مراسل العربيه ان الوضع
الانسانيه في شمال سوريا ماساوي بسبب نقص
الامكانات وان المؤسسات الطبيه في شمال
سوريا غير قادر على التعامل مع نوعيه
الاصابات الجهات الفاعله في شمال سوريا
اعلنت المنطقه منطقه منكوبه وقال ناشطون
في مناطق المعارضات السوريه ان عائلات
باكملها محاصره تحت انقاذ المباني
المنهاره المرصد السوري تحدث عن مئات
القتلى ومصير مجهول يواجه المئات مشيرا
الى ان 58 قريه وبلده في شمال سوريا شهدت
انهيارات كليه او جزئيه للمباني وان حجم
كارثه الزلزال يفوق الامكانات المتوفره في
شمال سوريا